[Music]
okay here's something really really good
that uh just happened and it's a
landmark breakthrough
scientists cure
a female hiv patient for the first time
using stem cell technology
looking red bro she's the first like
confirmed like cured hiv patient
function
so what about magic wait didn't he get
cured of hiv
sorry the way that you phrased it was
like it was like sounds are [ __ ] cool
but what about the ancient arts of magic
why are we utilizing this
you're like champion
i believe where are you talking about
magic johnson
[Applause]
i was like why are we not you know hocus
pocus you're better [ __ ]
so initially i was like what about magic
the gathering what about the dark arts
how come we're not using the dark arts
joe the way that you speak the way that
you phrase things you
you say something and then you pause for
long enough that my brain goes yeah what
about magic
so there's a lot of times you'll say
stuff what about
and then you finish the rest of your
thought in the other half of the
sentence but
a lot of times i'm like what about place
pauses but i'm sure while you were
saying that everybody in their head was
thinking what about magic cause in the
last video he was like everybody was
killing each other like black
friday
and me and him had a moment yeah we
looked at each other and just like
i just looked up at the lights
interesting
that's all i'm just like what the [ __ ]
i love it all right so yeah scientists
actually cured her in terms of magic
johnson i believe his thing was a result
of just accurately placed treatments
that were super successful yeah well and
you would have the money to take like
the ten thousand dollars with the pills
it was blood transfusion so it wasn't a
few stems it just replaced all of this
yeah he had so much [ __ ] money well i
knew the answer is just funnier to say
that right but like it slowly just
switched his blood over time every day
he had blood transfusions that's how
much [ __ ] money he had met new plasma
constantly he's not dark magic
or no well yeah
dude isn't that a [ __ ] like pitch for
a sci-fi movie where you just are a rich
person
and you just replace your blood with
like the blood of young people that's
what happened back in feature too
he had a change of blood
when he says that he rips off his old
skin went through the treatments for
like uh over a decade wow he's been at
it for a while yeah so his uh the i
guess like the count uh just reduced
constantly to the point where it just
left his body
yeah it's [ __ ] nuts that's pretty
amazing it's a fair trade right it's
someone at that level to be the uh i
guess like in some ways a poster boy for
aids that is pretty crazy though right
trade off is that we're going to [ __ ]
focus all these like experimental like
new technology things on you if you cure
aids doesn't that put condoms out of
business what
heard that brother heard that
heard that
i think the biggest std of children is
still gonna make me buy condoms
i mean it puts gonorrhea
true true at least fifty percent of the
condiments we've been out the game we
don't know what it's like anymore well i
mean
uh
stock is going to go through the roof
chlamydia stock yeah like the inventory
of committees you gotta get rid of that
yeah now we're condoms yeah for the big
short on that one the big shorts but
yeah so they were able to do that and
and i mean they've done it with male
patients before but this is the first
female i wonder why it's so different
like why is there such a gender gap [ __ ]
[ __ ] healing this [ __ ] laureen
willenberg the first female cured of hiv
via stem cell technology well maureen
looks like she she lived to a ripe old
age unless she's 20 years old she looks
like she uses magic
she yeah low-key bro
that's double doors like i said dude why
does she just use her magic what is her
job class let's ask she looks like she
works at hogwarts for sure yeah it looks
like you know she's i'm sure she's a
nice lady
i mean witches can be nice do we know
how she hates wasn't sharing heroin
needles
or is it from getting low then you put
that in the article right was it loads
busted in her mouth they left it up for
assumption they said that's more fun
that way
it was [ __ ] witch orgies
yeah which is we have oranges black
magic orgy witches be able to detect
aids probably
that's a psychic
get it right completely different kind
of magic
yeah ryan
can we ask that out loud psychics do you
think you think
do you think an hiv positive person can
go to a psychic and go just tell me if i
have aids or not
would they be right they should be able
to if they're an accurate person if
they're a good one
if they're a good one if you guys would
you [ __ ] around with some psychics no
i'm gonna go to a [ __ ] doctor
you're already gonna go to a dog about
this i'll give you choices okay would
you go to your uh chinese acupuncturist
like my mom's homies yeah yeah or
fortune teller chinese stuff they're
both my mom's homies so yeah so you
gotta pick between pick your poison
which one do you go to for yourself for
the best reading who do you trust the
most the fortune teller fortune teller
over the acupuncturist huh yeah because
i would go as a chiropractor i would
yeah because i would go there and say i
don't have it first and then see what
they say i'll give give it the opposite
yeah and then when you go you're going
to get the tarot that just says aids on
it
yeah i don't know yeah the aids card
yeah yeah that's a new one too that's
chariot death aids what else world life
can i tell you guys about the time that
i thought i was uh hiv positive yeah oh
[ __ ]
it's actually it's actually a funny
story oh cool
so good yeah so um i was experiencing
this like um
these like swellings on my face randomly
but at the time i turned like uh i think
it was like 30
and uh all of a sudden my both my cheeks
swell up super uh
big and i just flown into florida so i
go to the hospital i'm like what's going
on like a hamster
really really big wow do you have a
picture of my chance i didn't feel like
taking a picture
like when a dog bites a bee you didn't
vlog it bro no i didn't i was freaked
out so i go in the doctor puts me on
some like um benadryl like whatever they
can like via iv yeah and then um i knock
out and then i wake up and i'm like oh
must be done no it's even bigger the
doctor's right there i get the shrug of
the year they're just like i don't know
what's going on with the shrug
doctors
the swelling goes down after like a week
and then it reoccurs like the next uh
like five days after is the swelling
cheek one of the symptoms of hiv
uh yeah i mean your lymph node swelling
no they're on your cheek
here anywhere you have glands so uh
salivary glands you know like these
right here like anything glandular
swelling is like it's a pretty big uh
symptom but it wasn't me webmd myself it
was me going to a specific doctor that
they had recommended me to go to to
figure out what's going on with that uh
i went to this doctor
and and this is kind of [ __ ] up so
he's i don't know what it could be but
we're gonna do all the tests as we can
it wasn't until he asked me oh so what
do you do i told him i was a dancer and
then he said it might be hiv what what
dancers be dabbling with a lot of people
yeah yeah honestly yeah dancers would be
busting off he [ __ ] said that to me
yeah but why would he tell you break it
to you like that because he probably
thought he was a chip and dale's dad i
haven't even done the test yet and the
doctor already goes you know it might be
hiv he looked at you up and down what
the [ __ ] and he goes you be [ __ ]
normal right how did you feel i thought
i was already dead i was like i got
[ __ ] aids so like
i would maybe be like like maybe like
you raise an eyebrow and you're like
we're gonna do some tests yeah yeah
don't say hiv so chill and like it might
be hiv i didn't what did what was your
initial reaction inside yeah i died
dropped i died i died right there
because i didn't expect that i thought
it was just like an allergic reaction
like my eating too many mangoes or some
[ __ ] no so then he he i do the the test
and it's like every possible physical
test you can do to find out what's going
on in your body it's absolutely
everything all the blood work everything
bald coffin all of the above so then he
goes um so
we'll see the results in about 30 days
you're like
and i'm like i have 30 days to think
about this over what doctor did you go
to because when i do the [ __ ] blood
test p test for the std check right hiv
results come like in a day well that's
the thing is this isn't this isn't
technically a hiv test it's a full-on
everything test his verbal diagnosis was
just to throw that in there right after
i told him a little spice i think it was
just like a prejudice against he just
thought i was gay
no you honestly just thought i was gay
like a gay chip and dale's dancing yeah
he just thought he's gay you could just
tell like he's one of those guys you
just thought he was getting it like this
guy's too gay for me
i spent 30 days like just in a
heightened sense of anxiety i was like
when i get my diagnosis and
so to make matters worse like i
i was like thinking who gave it to me oh
[ __ ] and the last person had sex with my
ex so then i like i was trying to kind
of get answers out of her without saying
like this is my situation oh my god so
like trying to like tiptoe around it but
still get clues it was a [ __ ] up 30
days man and but then when i finally
came back in and i get the results
i'm like just [ __ ] give me the aids
man just tell me he goes he goes oh so
it's something called shogren syndrome
and it's an autoimmune where like your
glands will because it just attacks
itself after eating too many like uh
gluten
yeah i didn't know that oh so you better
stay away from the bread i developed a
gluten sensitivity that looked like
among other things hiv symptoms wow i i
was so why did he not say that first
because he thought he was gay so then i
get i go [ __ ] [ __ ] homophobic dick
so after he tells old results i go to
the parking lot and i instantly did the
highest backflip oh [ __ ]
oh and you know that guy was watching
from his office like [ __ ] dancing
i knew it i bet that guy used a
different word because he's a scumbag i
laid down on the pavement like this just
looking up at the sun that's the gayest
dancer i've ever seen yeah so yeah
sjogren's syndrome so autoimmune disease
[ __ ] flares up piece of [ __ ] doctor
you have it under control now yeah it's
fine i just don't i just don't eat as
much bread yeah so do so you eat
sandwiches and [ __ ] what happens like if
i eat too much bread like in a row like
if i have a like if we get a papa john's
pizza i go five slices the next day my
cheeks should be swollen oh so four
slices of your cutoff i don't know
depends if we're talking sparrows or
costco's depends we need to try this and
you'll find what your cutoff is yeah i
mean
it's been that way for years yeah
because my eczema flares up after i ate
a lot of sandwiches and i was like i'm
not even eating that much like milk and
stuff
but sandwiches why don't you get a taste
yeah what about it you should bread by
itself if you eat like a lot of bread or
pancakes we were doing that too like i
was putting [ __ ] butter and jam and
[ __ ] and i was being [ __ ] just
toasted bread [ __ ] bread bread i was
on a bread
west man yeah it's like
bread baked in a bread bread sandwich
you can develop it way later in life
like it started at 30 for me wow you can
develop like a lot of allergies later in
life like my friend just developed a
seafood allergy oh that sucks i was like
oh my heartbeat that means no more sushi
yeah so yeah no sushi no shrimp no
anything see i already got a dairy
allergy
is pretty brutal enough you know
diarrhea that's it
gary's pretty broad though
he'll upgrade that to hiv
i swear dude i never went to that guy
again but like yeah if you want to
[ __ ] was where was this hospital
downey
what was his name i don't even remember
i didn't want to [ __ ] dr homophobe
i have that stack of uh papers in my
like in my uh parents house still wow
and it's literally anything that could
be possibly wrong with me like my health
checks out except for that yes and i was
like damn if you're a doctor out there
don't [ __ ] just give that out and
just go it could be hiv they teach you
to not do that giant difference man yeah
you're not supposed to do that yeah
you're not saying maybe he didn't want
you to [ __ ] for 30 days just in case i
think you could have told you something
different and like gay guilt me i think
a little bit does it make you sweat and
be like oh no it's all the gay sex i've
been having i got a crush on you and it
made them feel uncomfortable themselves
she wanted to [ __ ] me that's it
you